pamela anderson and her fourth husband
dan hayhurst are calling it quits after
just a year of marriage e.t can confirm
he was working here and
i got stuck here during covet and
we stuck together
and that's that's actually you're
actually you're you're back together
that's the couple in happier times
zooming in from bed to share their love
story on the uk talk show loose women
early last year he's a good guy he's
like you know i would have maybe we
would have met well
he's the kind of guy i probably would
have met
if i would have stayed home and not went
around the world and got crazy i mean i
came home in one piece it's nice to be
with like a real
man
who can actually change a light bulb the
two met while dan was working on
pamela's property up in vancouver i'm
creating my my retirement there i'm
creating my little ranch my little not
you know with animals i'll have a lot of
animals but not like a ranch ranch but i
call it my little compound with my kids
and and future grandkids and stuff so
yeah i'm preparing pam and dan who
reportedly served as the baywatch babes
bodyguard tied the knot on christmas eve
2020 in the middle of coveted lockdown
in canada we had a really beautiful
quiet ceremony and
our witnesses were the first nations
people that came to do a cedar blessing
on us
get rid of all of our demons thesaurus
tells e.t the couple simply grew apart
as the pandemic raged on quote pamela
started to learn everything about dan
for better and for worse she fell out of
love and dan was not the guy she
previously thought he was i've had a few
ups and downs it doesn't matter marriage
is hard
i'm not doing it anymore this is the
second short-lived relationship for
pamela in the last couple of years in
february 2020 the actress had an
intimate wedding ceremony with film
producer john peters but the two called
things off 12 days later and pamela soon
revealed the pair never filed the legal
paperwork so they were never actually
husband and wife
people may misunderstand that i haven't
been with a lot of men in my life i've
been with a few men but and i've married
them and i believe in a monogamous
relationship so let's run through those
relationships pam tied the knot with
actor rick solomon twice first in 2007
and again in 2014 both of those
marriages lasted just a year too before
rick there was kid rock as long as he
likes me i'm happy pamela and the singer
dated for years and were married in 2006
but divorced in 2007 and then there's
pamela's most famous romance of all her
marriage to rocker tommy lee this is
forever i've never felt like this before
i've never felt like this in my life the
couple met in 1995 four days later they
got married three years later they
divorced but during their time together
they became parents to two sons brandon
thomas and dylan jagger i'm like thank
you more now they think you know now
they understand the decisions we made
tommy and i which is really funny i
guess looking at tommy and i and us
being you know strict parents but we are
those decisions pamela's referencing
well it might just be one of the biggest
celebrity scandals of all time it's
tommy lee sex tape i've never seen it
you've never seen it no it's fantastic
stop did you make did you make a mint
off of that you made not one dollar
i thought you guys
to stop the shenanigans now a whole new
generation will learn about that moment
in pop culture history thanks to hulu's
new series pam and tommy you know
anything at all about mr lee before you
met him
i knew he was the drummer for moppy crew
did you find him attractive i like to
smile
i still do
the show starts lily james and sebastian
stan as the titular couple we're so good
together
to everlasting love
and follows the aftermath of their
honeymoon sex tape being stolen and sold
online in the early days of the internet
the stolen property we never either of
us made anything from it and it was
stolen pamela is not directly involved
in the series though and the source
tells et it's quote painful for her to
relive quote it is shocking that this
series is allowed to happen without her
approval she feels so violated to this
day it brings back a very painful time
for her
what the wow is this
how many copies of this are out there
could be doesn't